don't think you realize just how messed
up the world is right now and where we
are heading governments are rotting your
savings through inflation we have Wars
breaking out across the world the United
States government has just said that
they want to fund both Wars despite the
fact that the US government is in 33
trillion dollar of debt we're seeing an
increase in authoritarianism the health
passports are not going anywhere they
still want to implement that by 2030 so
what's your plan you need time and
location Freedom you need to be able to
work from anywhere in the world you need
to be completely independent not
dependent on any single entity for money
or survival if you are not working
towards becoming fully independent and
Sovereign then you are going to get left
behind